So, yeah, I'm going to
try out something
a little bit different.
And it kind of depends
on the Wi-Fi working.
It's been a bit of
a nightmare.
It's probably a stupid idea.
So let's find out.
We're going to do an
interactive quiz.
These slides are going
to be interactive.
So, if you don't have a
web-enabled device in front of
you now, get it in
front of you.
A laptop or a phone.
It will work on both.
But make sure you've
got that ready.
It's a quiz, but it's really
just an excuse to string
together some bits of browser
trivia, to relate it to
performance stuff.
So what you'll need to do is get
on the Google guest Wi-Fi.
That's the SSID there.
And then, if you go to this
lovely URL, which is my laptop
here, so that's 192.168.156.69
port 3000.
And there's a clue.
Yes, it's a node server.
Fair enough.
Yeah, if you're watching the
live stream, nah, that's not
going to work.
Sorry, just play the game using
your mind or whatever.
Just play with yourself.
No, wait, doesn't matter.
OK, just move on.
Once you go to this URL you'll
be asked to enter a username
and password.
Just make up any old password.
It's going to be stored in
plain text on my machine.
So don't use your credit card
number unless you wish to make
a donation.
All donations are gratefully
received.
The reason I'm asking for a
password is if you want to
switch devices halfway through,
like if you start
running out of batteries
or whenever.
You can just enter the username
and password again on
another device and pick up
from where you left off.
Now I hacked this thing together
quite quickly.
You could probably break it
by trying to break it.
So please don't do that.
I've at least made sure little
Bobby Tables can play.
So if you're in the room,
you're all right.
Is everyone getting
access to it?
Is it kind of working?
Wow, brilliant!
I want to stress that this quiz
is tough, and I've seen
it catch out people who do
this sort of stuff-- this
minor details of browsers--
for a living.
It catches them out.
So if you're the kind of person
who flips tables over
when you don't win, then maybe
stay away from tables for a
little bit, because this
could get rough.
OK, I'm going to get this huge,
horrible Helvetica off
the screen.
Oh, of course, what kind of quiz
would be complete without
a grand prize?
The Chromebook Pixel is Google's
latest laptop,
featuring an i5 1.8 gigahertz
processor, four gigabytes of
RAM, and a touchscreen with a
higher GPI than a MacBook Pro.
Couldn't get ahold
of one of those.
Sorry, they wouldn't
give me one.
Never mind.
But if you do win, then
we will swag you.
We will swag you good.
You're quite dazzled by that.
I thought you might not, so I
thought I'd go all in, like,
yeah, look at that stuff,
a neon thing!
A Glass!
Have you seen one
of those before?
And a cup.
Brilliant.
OK.
The lens flares are
sold separately.
Sorry about that.
Let's get started.
We're going to start
off really simple.
Image in HTML.
You've done that before.
Fair enough.
OK here is a div.
The div has a source,
like an image might.
Which browsers do you think
are going to make
a request for that?
Now on your phones, on your
laptops at the moment it
should have given you the
options for this question.
If it hasn't, just
hit refresh, and
you should get them.
Now when we're talking about
these browsers, we're talking
about the latest version
of them, the
latest stable release.
You get one point for each one
you get right, and you will
lose a point for each
one you get wrong.
So if you say Firefox doesn't
make a request, and it does,
you will lose a point there.
You can assume the
HTML5 doctype.
And there's nothing funky in the
head, like a BaseType that
might throw things off.
There's nothing--
there's no trickery going on.
And what we're seeing here is a
live read-out of the opinion
of the room.
So the needle will swing one
way when you think yes, it
will swing the other way when
you think no, though the
direction is randomized for each
question so you cannot
just vote along with the room.
You will be probably getting
it wrong if you do that.
Right, OK that's probably
enough time.
If you haven't answered yet,
answer quickly because I'm
going to close the question
in three, two, one.
And OK, so the needle's kind of
going roughly in the middle
which means, collectively
you don't have a clue.
Well done, everyone.
You're kind of thinking yes
in, well, most of the
browsers, kind of, more strongly
in Internet Explorer.
It's almost like you've
been bitten by that
browser in the past.
The answer is, of
course, none.
Not in any of the browsers.
None of them going to do that.
Well done, the people
who got it right.
Four people by the sounds
of things, actually.
Well done.
But this is not as
mad as it seems.
So in XHTML2 you
could do this.
You could have any elements,
such as a div with a source,
and the browser would replace
the element with the content
of that resource.
And it was kind of a good
idea, or it was the
start of a good idea.
Because you could take rich
semantic content, and replace
it with an image.
It may be Alt attribute
completely redundant.
Pretty cool.
But XHTML2 had the backwoods
incompatibility issues, and it
carried with it XML's draconian
error handling.
And once you invite XML into
your home, it XML's
everything.
It XMLs all over the carpet,
up the walls.
And in the same way that Smurfs
stick the word Smurf in
front of everything to make it a
Smurf thing, XML sticks X at
the start of everything.
You don't want HTML.
You want XHTML.
You don't want Frames.
You want XFrames.
You don't want Forms.
You can have XForms.
If you let XML take over your
life, it will turn your
boyfriend or girlfriend into an
exboyfriend or girlfriend.
And XML's cool with that because
you don't need a
partner because you've got XML
to look after you now.
It seems fitting that in
2009 XHTML2 became an
ex-specification, and we didn't
care about it anymore.
And no browser's ever
implemented source on
something like a div.
But what about this.
We've got an image element.
It's got a source.
Which browsers are going
to make a request?
Now, notice that I have spelled
"image" incorrectly in
terms of HTML.
Does the browser treat this
like an unknown element?
Or does it do something
special?
I mean, we saw XML was
too draconian, too
strict for the web.
But is HTML this lenient, or are
the browsers more lenient
than the spec in this case?
So we're seeing you're kind of
leaning towards one way in
pretty much all the browsers.
Ah, you're changing your mind,
going back into the middle.
We're going to keep this
moving quickly.
So just make a decision.
I'm going to close the question
in three, two, one,
and it's closed.
So, you're kind of thinking,
pretty much
yes in all the browsers.
And you would be absolutely
correct.
In all of them, it will make
a request for the image.
I know in these situations it
doesn't have to show the
image, we're just talking
about making a request.
But in this case, all of the
browsers will actually show
the image as well.
You see, back in the past--
I don't know if you remember
the past-- but one browser
decided that I-M-G was too
difficult for developers to
remember, and that image
should work as well.
And we've been stuck with
that ever since.
Now which browser vendor
do you think we have
to blame for this?
Oh yes, of course, it is
Mosaic, back in 1993.
The people who invented
the image tag.
They did this.
And a study in 2005 showed that
like 0.2% of pages were
using this incorrectly spelled
image, so all the browsers
have to support it for pretty
much forevermore.
The World WG recognized this
and added it to the spec.
This is the pausing spec, and
you can see there, start tag
if it's image, change the
token names to img and
reprocess it.
Don't ask.
But recently I-M-A-G-E was
using a clever hack.
Alexie10 came up with this.
So you would use this on your
page instead of an image, this
block of sort of svg with
an image inside it.
And what it'll do is it'll throw
and svg in browsers that
support svg, and it'll do
a png in other browsers.
So a modern browser will
parse it like this.
Ah, OK, that's an svg element.
OK, it's going to
be 100 by 100.
That's fine.
Oh, and this is an svg image,
because in svg, image elements
are spelled fully, I-M-A-G-E.
Oh, it's got
a width and a height.
That's great.
And I'm going to load img.svg.
Because this is how you define
the source for an image in svg
because it's part of XML.
And why have a link when
you can have an XLink?
And then it sees this,
and it goes pfffft.
That means absolutely nothing
to svg images, so I'm
going to ignore it.
Whereas an older browser, maybe
Android2, IE8, they'll
parse it like this, [GRUNTS], I
mean, going to ignore that.
Oh look, the developer
spelled image wrong.
OK I'm going to use that.
It's 100 by 100.
Pffft, Woah.
Developer got high.
I'm going to ignore that.
And I'm going to load img.png.
It's great, so you've got this
kind that doesn't require
JavaScript.
And you're switching between
the two image formats.
So we got kind of excited
about it.
And we started tweeting
The mistake we made is
we didn't test it.
So a few of us started testing
it and we found something
interesting.
All of these browsers
spot svg.
Which ones download
both images?
They shouldn't.
And I'll give you a clue.
It's doesn't go one way or the
other for all browsers.
Some of the browser are
doing it differently.
So you're going to have to pick
the browser or browsers
that you think get this
wrong because not all
of them get it wrong.
I'm going to close
the question--
woah, oh dear--
oh no, no, OK, we've got some
IE fans in the room.
Closing the question
in three, two, one.
OK, so you're edging towards
Internet Explorer being the
bad guy here.
And in this case you
are correct.
As a group you're doing
quite well.
You should all form a company
of something.
It's great.
So all the browsers here, all
the latest versions, they have
two parsers inside.
Relatively new thing for
browsers to have.
But these ones, they
all have it.
One parser runs ahead as quickly
as it can and picks up
things that it should download,
like images,
scripts, all of that
sort of stuff.
The other parser does the heavy
lifting, like building
that the DOM tree and passing
scripts and all that stuff.
This has a surprisingly large
benefit-- you know, Illya was
posting about this.
This study that was done
through 2000 sites.
And it had a 20% speed
improvement.
That's pretty incredible.
That's time to get to
DOM content loaded.
In order to be quick, this of a
pre-parser, this first one,
is a little bit stupid.
In Internet Explorer, it's
a little bit too stupid.
And it kind of gets
over excited.
And it's like, I'm going to show
a png, I'm going to show
a png, yep, here I go, I'm going
to show png, here is
goes, no, actually no, it's
an svg, never mind.
It kind of sees the image but it
misses the svg context, so
it picks up the wrong source.
And then the main parser comes
along and goes pfft,
what are you doing?
No, this is as svg thing, and
downloads the correct thing.
The moral here is, don't just--
like, if there's some
kind of performance advice
going on, don't just
blindly trust it.
In Chrome, we say, use
tools not rules.
And it rhymes so it must
be true, right?
So be on the look-- but
also be on the lookout
for existing tests.
If someone's done the legwork
for you, and you can just sort
of run that test yourself.
One of my favorite stories in
science involves this guy,
August Weismann.
He wanted to disprove that
evolution was learned.
Like, if you had some kind of
life experiences, that that
would be passed to
your children.
He wanted to disprove that was a
thing, because it wasn't the
Darwin evolution.
So he took some mice, and he cut
their tails off, and bred
them together.
And then the next generation,
he cut their tails off and
bred them together as well.
And the theory was, well if
evolution is learned, we're
going to start getting mice
born without tails.
And he was quite a way into this
research, until someone
went, ah you do realize, August,
that the Jewish people
have been carrying out
this test a lot
longer than you have.
[LAUGHTER]
And he was like, [INAUDIBLE].
Fair enough, I'll just.
I'll--
Yeah, OK, job done.
So yeah, don't reinvent the
wheel unless you want to learn
a lot about wheels.
And that could be
cool sometimes.
OK, what about this?
I've got an image.
It's inside a div that
is display none.
This image is not going
to be displayed.
But which browsers are going
to request the URL and
download the image regardless?
So, we'll do it quickly.
We're going to go for-- oh, are
we starting to think IE is
going to do some different?
People are thinking Firefox
is going to
do something different.
I'm going to close the question
in three, two, one.
There we go.
The countdown's going to old,
but I'm going to do it for
every question anyway.
OK, so we're sort of
saying, yes in IE.
Maybe no in Safari.
No in Chrome.
And meh, maybe in Firefox.
The answer is yes
in all of them.
They are all going to download
the image in this case.
And this behavior is part of
the specification as well.
In the beginning, there
is nothing.
Right?
And then the browser gets
sprayed with HTML text.
And then from that, it's going
to construct this tree of
elements that, as Paul
was explaining
earlier, is the DOM.
When one of these things is
constructed, the constructor
steps for that elements
are run.
And if we look at the spec for
image, it's quite complicated,
for you know when you'd think
it'd be a very simple thing.
But this is the image stuff.
They all run synchronously.
Step 14, fetch the image.
No mention of CSS.
No mention of anything
like that.
And that's good in some ways,
because it means the browser
can start the image downloading
before the CSS is there.
The pre-parser can
deal with it.
Downside is, well we couldn't
do polyfills to things like
responsive images because by the
time JavaScript gets there
to do something clever, the
images already started
downloading.
You're just going to trigger
a second request by
changing the source.
This won't be a problem
in the future.
The resources, priority spec has
this postpone attribute,
which means the image won't
download if it's display none.
And it allows the browser to
avoid downloading it even if
it's just out-of-view
on the page as well.
So you don't have to rely on
these heavy scroll events for
image lazy loading.
OK, what if we're using CSS?
Does visibility matter then?
Once again that image is not
going to display because it's
inside an element that
is display none.
We saw here that the image would
download in this case.
But what about in CSS?
Is it going to do something
different?
Does visibility matter here?
Some of the browsers going to
do something different?
I'm going to close the question
in three, two--
ooh, going right
to the middle.
Collectively, once
again, no clue.
Don't worry about it, guys.
It's quite difficult.
What's the answer?
None of the browsers will
make a request here.
And that's kind of
cool, right?
We want to be able to rely
on that kind of behavior.
Slightly different one.
What about now?
Same thing again.
The image is not going to be
rendered because it's on a
display none element.
But it's not inside a display
none element, It is on a
display none element.
So we saw it was, the browsers
weren't downloading before.
What about now?
Do the browsers do something
different?
Do they all download it?
Do they all not download it?
I mean, they don't need it.
It's not going to be rendered.
I'm going to close
the question in
three, two, one, done.
All right, we're saying no in
pretty much every browser.
Most browsers will download
it in this case.
Only Firefox won't.
So what's going on here?
Well once you've got some DOM
elements on the page, as Paul
was explaining before, they're
going to get their styles
calculated where the browser
goes to see which of your
cascaded styles of your font
tags, if you're from the '90s,
which styles apply to each
element individually?
But not all-- not everything
gets its style calculated.
So you've got these two elements
at the bottom.
No style calculation.
And the reason is, this div at
the top here turned out to be
display none.
And the browsers shortcuts
because it knows the styles of
these elements have no impact on
the rendering of the page.
So it doesn't bother.
It takes a shortcut.
So if these have background
images, the browser never
finds out about it.
If the display none element has
a background image, the
browser does find
out about it.
And that's why we see most
browsers downloading it at
that point.
Firefox is a little
bit smarter here.
But if you use something like
visibility hidden or opacity
zero, Firefox will be
downloading as well.
Who's getting it right
according to the
specification?
Everyone is!
Great!
The specification says
absolutely nothing about this.
There's this tiny note that says
the browser may optimize.
It may avoid downloading images
that are out of view,
even if there's another
element over the top.
The browser may avoid
downloading at this point.
No browsers are that
smart yet.
This kind of freedom in the
specifications is great
because it means the browser can
do what's right given the
situation, and the kind of
device, and the network
connectivity, et cetera,
et cetera.
But it's also kind of scary
because this is where you're
going to get the browsers
doing different
things, as we saw here.
But I kind of like that.
I think that's the diversity
that makes the web great.
It's not one company
driving forward
with its own interests.
It's lots of companies driving
forward in different
directions.
And we get this sort of car
crash, but a car crash with a
happy ending.
And that web that
we have today.
So if you want to avoid
downloading backgrounds in
CSS, hiding the element
isn't enough.
You need to put it inside
something that is hidden so
the virus won't find--
it won't even look
at that element.
But when you do that, realize
you are relying on just what
the browsers do.
It is not specs' behavior.
The only surefire way is, don't
let the browser find out
about the background image.
Take the class off until
you need it.
Or don't put the element in
the DOM until you need it.
All right, things have been
quite easy so far.
Let's get JavaScript involved.
What do you think?
Creating an image elements--
once again I've
spelled image wrong--
I'm applying a source to it.
It is not in the document.
So it's not going to
be displayed yet.
I have it spelled wrong.
We saw the browsers correcting
for that before.
But that was in HTML.
What about in the DOM?
Is it going to be different?
I'm going to close the question
in three, two, one,
all right, done.
OK so we're kind of edging
towards yes in most browsers.
It is yes in most browsers,
except Firefox.
Firefox does something
different here.
And there are two parts
to this explanation.
We saw before that the DOM
builds up and these creation
steps for elements are run.
But even if you create the
elements and it's not part of
a document, that's still going
to run those creation steps.
And we saw before, step
14, fetch the image.
We can use this to our advantage
because you can make
a GET request to any URL by
making the image elements in
assigning a source.
And you could use the image
element constructor.
It's a tiny bit of code.
You can make a request
anywhere.
This is kind of how Google
Analytics communicates back to
the server.
Oh yeah, but Firefox didn't
make a request.
So what's going on there?
It's because we spelled image
wrong, and most browsers--
Chrome, Safari, IE-- will give
us an HTML image element when
we do that.
Firefox will give us
an HTML element.
It's not an image.
You add it to the page.
It will not show an image.
And do you know what, it's the
only one getting it right.
We saw before that the
specification says, if you
encounter a start tag,
you can correct it.
But this is the parsing spec.
We bypass the parsing spec by
creating the element in
JavaScript.
So, yeah, actually technically
it should have returned an
HTML unknown element, but you
know, it's getting it closer
to right than the
other browsers.
I think I kind of preferred it
when the web, before all the
browsers, like there was one
bad guy, and all the other
browsers seemed perfect.
It was like an orchestra and
Internet Explorer 8 was just
this screaming child hitting
two cymbals together.
But then we finally got
rid of the screaming
child with the cymbal.
And then we started conducting
again and we went, oh,
actually everyone's
out of tune.
We just didn't notice because of
the screaming cymbal child.
Oh.
All right, let's get
CSS involved again.
What about this?
So, as before, creating a div,
I'm going to give it a
background image.
So I'm not creating an image.
I'm creating a div, giving
it a background image.
We saw here that images were
downloaded at this point.
Is it different with CSS?
Do different browsers
do different stuff?
So we are kind of hedging
towards the [INAUDIBLE].
Oh wow, it sort of swung
the other way.
Closing the question
in three, two, one.
All right, so we're edging
towards yes in everything.
Wrong ends the lot of you.
No browser will download here.
And this is kind of the same
as the display non case.
It's not in the document, so the
browser's not going to go
looking for the styles, because
it doesn't need to
know the style information
because it knows it's not
going to render.
All right, going to be cruel.
Same thing, but I'm going
to add it to the DOM.
And then I'm going
to take it away.
In the same block of JavaScript,
will the browser
see that element in the document
long enough to
actually trigger the download?
What do you think?
I'm going to close the question
in three, two, one.
We're edging towards
yes in everything.
Wrong again.
None of the browsers.
None of them.
The browser doesn't think about
styles or layout until
as late as possible, which
normally means when it needs
to render something.
And this is going to change
any pixels because
JavaScript's going to be
blocking the chance to do some
of that painting stuff.
What about this?
I'm adding it to the document.
I'm going to ask for
its text content.
It's an empty element.
Text content is going
to be empty as well.
And I'm going to remove
it again.
Does that trigger different
behavior in the browser?
Element's completely empty.
So you know.
But is that going to trigger
the browser to go, ah yeah,
I'm actually going to get
that background image.
I'm going to close the question
in three, two, one.
What have you said?
Ugh, you don't know.
Fair enough.
Yes, is tricky.
No, none of the browser
at this point.
I am going somewhere
with this.
I promise you.
Getting the text content of
an element is pretty easy.
It's just going to go and pick
up the text notes, doesn't
need to look at the
style or anything.
What about this one?
Inner HTML?
Same as before, but instead of
text content, going to ask for
the older innerHTML.
Oh wow, IE's doing something
different from everyone else.
Interesting.
Going to close the question
in three, two, one.
All right, so you said yes in IE
and no in everything else.
Bloody hell, you're right.
Well done.
Yeah, IE makes a request.
And the reason for
that is because--
I don't know.
Some things in the world
cannot be explained.
Like why it takes three attempts
to plug in a USB
cable, even though there's
only two possibilities.
These things just cannot
be explained.
Moving on.
Similar again.
Instead of inner HTML,
it's inner text.
What do the browsers do here?
Do they do something
different?
We saw IE's quite request-happy
with innerHTML.
Does it do something different
within the text?
Does it trigger requests in
any of the other browsers?
I can promise you I am going
somewhere with this.
Closing the question
in three, two, one.
There's quite a strong opinion
of no across all the browsers.
Sorry, guys.
Yes, in everything
except Firefox.
And this actually makes sense.
Let's make a div.
We make a div, we give it
a background image.
I'm going to give inner HTML,
where it's got Hello World,
and the div is a div around
the world or whatever.
Text content is Hello World.
As you might expect, the inner
text has a line break in it.
And-- well this is how it in
IE, Chrome, and Safari--
because inner text is more like
what you would get if you
copy and pasted the elements,
the text of the elements.
And because is a block-level
element-- or it certainly is
in this example--
it gets a new line.
So if we run this, the browser
goes, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Text content, easy enough.
Inner text--
oh!
Inner text is style dependant.
So I'm going to have a look at
the styles of the elements.
And oh!
It's got a background image.
That's interesting.
I'll download that.
And that's why we see most
browsers doing it.
Firefox doesn't download at this
point, because it doesn't
support inner text.
It's the only browser
that doesn't.
So it just returns undefined
at that point.
But if you use any of these,
apart from inner text, like
anything that's going to get
some style data from the page,
FireFox would have started
the download as well.
So Paul was talking about
this earlier.
You can start doing layout
thrashing if you start doing
these reads and writes.
So you'll trigger extra
layouts, et cetera.
The browser is quite clever
about this stuff.
It will batch changes
together .
If you do this, like display
non-block, non-block, et
cetera, et cetera, it
loads the width.
This is actually a really
light piece of code.
It's not tricky for the browser
the understand because
it's going to ignore--
all right, I hope that's not
my cue to get off because
that's very passive
aggressive.
So it will just take the last
change that you make.
Oh that's nice.
This is great but it can lead
to unexpected results.
Let's have a look at a
practical example.
Paul and I, we want
to go over there.
You can tell because
we're pointing.
Let's do it with code.
We're going to start
at left zero.
We're going to transition left
one second, go to 100%.
We run that code,
and it works.
Yay, we solve the world's
problems with code.
Now, we're very happy
at this point.
But let's run the code again.
Nothing happened.
And this is because the browser
is going to ignore
this first right of left.
It's just going to batch
them together.
It's only going to listen
to our last right here.
And it's 100%, we're 100%
already, so nothing happens.
We can fix this by enforcing
a synchronous layout here.
Because that forces the browser
to go and look at all
the styles of all the elements
in the page, and it realizes,
oh yeah, we are supposed
to be at left zero.
So when we make the
next changes, it
will start from zero.
We run this code as many times
as we want, and it works.
You might have encountered
this kind of behavior and
tried to use set timer or
something to get around it.
No, you can just force
a layout like this.
Right, OK last question.
Let's go through this quickly
because I'm going to be
chucked off the stage
in a few seconds.
Imagine a page full
of lorem ipsum.
It looks like this.
595 pixels across.
Media query, min width 600.
Min width, so you know,
we wouldn't really
be expected to display.
Which browsers are going to
download that gif anyway?
Are the browsers going to
do something different?
And you say, you know, would
we expect it to even
display that gif?
You know, who knows?
Last question, so make
it a good one.
Closing it in three, two, one.
Straight down the middle.
I have--
I feel like I've broken
you as an audience.
I'm very sorry.
What happens here?
IE and Firefox will download.
And they will actually display
the background as well.
And this is quite sneaky.
My measurements did not include
the scroll bar.
With the scroll bar it brings
it over 600 pixels.
Now, they don't call
me cunning Jake--
they don't actually call
fair enough.
This seems insane to me, to
include this scroll bar width.
What's the use?
It's has a 200 pixel
scrollbar.
Why should I care about that?
But including the scrollbar is
mandated by the specification.
It's interesting.
And Chrome and Safari are
breaking the spec here.
It's fixed in the Chrome
nightlies.
It's not fixed in the
WebKit nightlies.
Why is the scrollbar included?
Well, imagine this
bit of code.
I'm no scrollbar.
And then when the width gets to
600, I'm going to introduce
a scroll bar.
500 pixels, that's fine.
We get 601.
Ah, we need to put
a scroll bar in.
Oh, no we're less
than 600 pixels.
We'll take it away.
And so on and so on and so on.
In reality, it doesn't get stuck
in a loop, but here we
can see what Safari does.
I've got a background picture
and a scrollbar coming in at a
particular width.
And we'll see, as I'm
only moving--
I'm only making it bigger.
I'm not, you know,
moving both ways.
Now we can see that the
background image
flickers on and off.
And then once we get beyond the
width of the scroll bar,
it stabilizes.
And that it.
Let's have a look
at the rankings.
Don't worry, if you haven't
scored great, it won't
actually show your name
on the screen.
And it's only going to
show the top 10.
So don't worry too much.
Who've we got?
prettyFlyForAWiFi Very good.
Who's that?
Excellent.
Right.
So I will swag you
good and proper.
Oh god, you've done quite
really, really well.
OK that's my time.
Thank you very much guys.
Cheers, bye!
[APPLAUSE]